spring and Dan Bickley talk show host
lead columnist for Arizona Sports 98.7
FM joining us from Nashville Bick how
are you this morning
VP it's been a long time man I tell you
one of the worst things about having bad
teams to covering Arizona's I don't get
to make guest appearances I don't relive
all the angst
I caused Rich Eisen you may get Kyler
Murray and Zion Williamson a little bad
no that would make us relevant overnight
now wouldn't it you know I've said all
along the be Arizona there's two things
here the Arizona Cardinals should take
Kyler Murray I continually I continue to
think that they will not take him I
don't know if they are going to have the
courage to put everything including the
GM's job on the line for a quarterback
who is a 5 foot 10 and 1/8 but the way I
look at it man you've got Kliff
Kingsbury who is a failed college coach
he is coming to the NFL you've got guys
like Sean Payton who are already
salivating waiting to play this guy
waiting to expose this guy you have
hired all of the assistant coaches for
Kliff Kingsbury he effectively has no
real power or authority or really any
credibility yet in this organization and
you can see how fast the bottom could
fall out of this tub if he is not any
good or refused and over and said so
you've got to double down and give him a
guy that he can work magic with because
if you're going down this path like
Daniel Jeremiah just said you've got to
go full on and give Kliff Kingsbury this
guy but I don't think they're gonna do
it did you see enough from Josh Rosen
last year that you say alright I'll give
him another year or he's still a
franchise but you know a chance to be a
franchise quarterback it was the
weirdest thing watching him last year
everything we thought we knew about Josh
Rosen coming out of UCLA the fact that
we thought he was aloof maybe a little
petulant maybe entitled he heard Rex
Ryan rip him for being a tennis player
his personality and is the most
ridiculous thing what's wrong with a
good tennis player
so anyways this is it to me Josh Rosen
proved that he is physically and
emotionally and in in terms of maturity
far better than anybody thought yet his
accuracy and his arm strength in his
delivery was a little under
and there was some bad habits that
cropped up at the end of the season that
a lot of us explained away due to the
fact that you know look he's got no
offensive line he's got no skill players
to speak of
they basically thrown this kid to the
wolves and any survived and he topped it
out so he proved some things that we
that that were about you know his image
and who he was he proved those wrong but
the quarterback itself he kind of left
some questions hanging out there and
it's amazing how this offseason he's
it's turned him into a sympathetic
figure in Arizona Dan which is kind of
the darndest thing I've seen because you
know here's this kid from a rival
paxville school come to Arizona
now suddenly just because people can
relate to having a bad boss and and
they're going look you drafted up to
take Josh Rosen you throw them to the
wolves you made them play under one of
the worst offensive systems and
offensive coordinators we've ever seen
and and now you're gonna take the job
away from them you've turned into a
sympathetic figure almost like a
murderer in Arizona and it's bizarre how
good he's become in the last couple of
months without playing a game bigger
risk
Kliff Kingsbury as your coach Kyle
Armour is your quarterback i I think
Kliff Kingsbury is your head coach I
think Kyler Murray I you know I've I'm
not an expert at this stuff but he has
got elite level released he's got elite
footwork he's the twitchiness
quarterback I have ever seen and if he
can stay in one piece in the NFL I think
he is going to be sensational
Kliff Kingsbury as I said you know it
being an NFL head coach you are
commanding a small army of men Kliff
Kingsbury has never commanded men he has
commanded kids and is Kliff Kingsbury
going to be able to go and I approve the
hire I like it it's outside the box it's
something I'm interested in covering
it's something I'm interested in
watching but there this thing is fraught
with danger
because his Kliff Kingsbury going to go
and rip into some of his players the way
Bruce Arians did is he gonna be able to
speak hard truth to players when he has
never coached it down in the NFL he's
gonna be tough things for him especially
if he gets off to a to a slow start I
like to hire but it's it's a dangerous
road they're traveling down in Arizona
hey Stan Bickle a talk show host lead
columnist for Arizona Sports 98.7 fm my
point is the if you're gonna bring in
Kliff Kingsbury than I'm bringing in
Kyler Murray
if you stayed with Bruce
Ariane's I don't think you're bringing
in Kyler's Murray and you know that's
that's where if I'm only in I'm all-in
it's not then I'm not taking Tyler
Murray that's exactly right
and that's what kind of is well that's
where I met with this whole thing with
Steve climate and I really believe that
that they've got to kind of align their
priorities and get their minds straight
before this craziness begins you know on
the streets of Nashville last night and
I'm sure you guys saw this as well they
ran that little dress rehearsal and and
they showed on the stage the Arizona
Cardinals the pick is in and then
there's all you know this pomp and
circumstance and I thought to myself
these 10 minutes that the Cardinals are
going to be on the clock if they keep if
they keep their intentions and and what
they're going to do airtight and if
there is no pre-draft trade those 10
minutes are going to be riveting
compelling stuff because nobody really
knows what they're going to do the thing
is is their GM he's a guy that I never
believed he was in danger of losing his
job after a three and thirteen season
after the debacle of hiring Steve Wilkes
after dealing with Patrick Peterson's
unhappiness last year
well now you're going into another year
and I do think his job is next on the
line and hiring Kliff Kingsbury is nice
and it's out of the box and you can say
look at how willing I am to risk
everything but if you if you go now and
say look i if you think in terms of job
security it's going to be awfully hard
for a general manager to draft Kyler
Murray when you have so many needs on
this football team but to me once you
once you once you signed on with Kliff
Kingsbury this is the road you have to
go you need to unveil a brand new day a
new declaration of who the Cardinals are
and just take it from here and hit the
ground running with it it's interesting
too because as you know well Kyler
Murray doesn't come off very well in
public I was with him in Indianapolis
one day you had that ill-fated interview
with him his people skills they're not
the greatest and even worse he doesn't
seem to really care and I don't know if
that's because of his family if it is
handlers if it's because he is so
constricted of what he should and
shouldn't say in this process but but
there's that to consider to the
popularity of this kid and how people
are gonna relate to him I believe if
things go well this guy can do to the
NFL with Steve Nash did to the NBA he's
going to be this
your dog quarterback that is going to
send this message to all these young
players that look if you're under six
feet tall you can be an NFL quarterback
I think he can have that kind of impact
on the game I just like to know more of
who this kid really is and I hope the
Cardinals have a clearer picture I will
give you the power to pick if you want
Sion Williamson in Phoenix or you want
Kyler Murray in Arizona oh wow what a
great question I would take I'm gonna
take Sion Williams you know only because
I think the sun's even even with their
owner who just continues to do Daffy
things at a tenure of this franchise I
would take Zion Williamson just to pair
him up with Devin Booker and and and
everything they've got DeAndre Aiden and
because you know I love watching Kyler
Murray play football but I've never seen
a powerful word play basketball like a
Zion Williamson
Vick behaved down there good to talk to
you again love UDP take care boy that's
Stan Bickley talk show host lead
columnist for arizona sports 98.7 FM for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on VR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app